[Music]
he's been going to intimacy parties sex
parties yes I found out he has been
crossdressing he has engaged in the
opposite sex he admitted to me he was
cheating with a 20-some year old he said
he has a sex addiction oh it's so
[Music]
messy what is up this is John with Dr
John Del show welcome welcome welcome I
hope you're doing all right if you want
to be on this show we're talking about
mental and emotional health we're
talking about your marriage we're
talking about whatever is going on in
your life your relationship with your
kids your kids schools your workplace
whatever you got going on give me a buzz
at 1844 693 3291 that's 1844 693
3291 or go to John dooney.com
askas we are recording this episode
right before we leave for the Christmas
holidays and everybody's burned
out a little bit little
bit yeah see Kelly's not even speaking
in complete sentences
anymore tomorrow's the last show before
the holiday and let's just say it can't
come soon
enough well I would like to tell you
that I would like to spend more time
with you but I I hear your what you're
saying loud and clear you I believe your
words were I'm barely hanging
on I don't know what you're talking
about I don't think I said that I'm I
did actually I said that let's go out
to Northern Oklahoma otherwise known as
Vancouver Canada what's up David how we
doing
brother hey Dr thank you for taking my
call thanks for calling in man what's
up hi so um just have a question I need
help here um how do I tell my parents
that I haven't been going to school for
the Last 5
Years uh do you have a
pen yeah I got uh got my laptop here all
right type
this dear Mom and
Dad yep I have not been going to school
for the last five
years
period how about how about
that yeah um tell me about it what
happened man what happened
yeah I like I know i' I've been planning
to like I just find the right time
there's not gonna be a right time dude
you're just gon to have to do it but
tell me tell me what happened for five
years you've been lying to your folks
what have you been doing with the money
tuition what you been
doing yeah so I haven't been taking any
money for tuition um also in the last
five years uh some stuff happened with
my mom um her mental health has been
getting worse uh she she got diagnosed
with uh delusional disorder so right now
she's uh not in the best shape so I'm
just scared like telling her this this
news is just going to make her even
worse so maybe she's not the best person
to tell what about your
dad my
dad I know my dad has been stressed out
too because of my mom and and I want to
tell him and I know he I think he knows
there's something up with me
but like how I'm just scared like how
should I tell them like hold on let's
let's back up let's back up dude um what
happened five years ago that you started
telling the story and you've been lying
for five years what have you been doing
for five
years yeah so during these five years I
know that I had to do something not just
waste time um so I I got a good job uh I
renting my own place so I'm not there um
I'm making money myself so I can uh I
can take care of
myself so I what are you doing what are
you
doing uh I'm an account manager at a
marketing company right now okay and
you're making a good living do you have
a good career
trajectory yeah do you like
marketing yeah do you need a a degree
for the job you have have you deceived
your
bosses no uh so even my know what's
going on with my situation and uh I've
been doing a great job so I've been here
for a while a couple years so I've been
doing great and they love me here and I
love my job so why do you why do you
feel like have you been actively lying
to your parents why do you feel like you
need to come clean with
them because I don't want to like have
this like lie forever and I can feel in
my chest like whenever they ask me about
school like I it's just hard to talk to
them about that and I I know they they
deserve to know the truth yeah
especially how they deserve I mean if
you've been telling them if they ask you
like hey how's school going you're like
I got finals coming up they're going to
be tough if you're doing that then yeah
man stop lying to your parents dude
um I want to get at the root of this and
I'm asking this not because it's okay to
perpetuate a half a decade lie to your
parents it's never okay
and I want to know why you felt you had
to do this in the first place and what
I'm asking is have your parents been if
your mom's just now getting um diagnosed
with some sort of um delusion
disorder and your dad is
struggling it's never okay to lie but
was it an unsafe place for you to be
honest and say hey I'd rather just go to
the workforce instead of go to college
um or were you just did you take a
chicken way out when you were 18 or 19
you just don't know how to how to reel
it back in
now I think I at first it was the
chicken Way Out J when I was 18 fresh
out of high school um I did try to tell
them like in high school that after when
I started my first semester in uh
University that they uh I didn't want to
be a doctor anymore and my mom pretty
much like uh guilted me into it saying
like uh you're wasting my my talent or
like we work so hard um we just want you
to be a doctor I guess it's like
following my uh my parents's dream but
which is mine so I felt really guilty
about that and then couple years after
that um mom's mental health got worse
and I just couldn't find the right time
to tell them
I want you to pick up a book um check
real quick um Kelly it's either I think
it's Lindsey
Gibson it's called adult children of
emotionally immature
parents okay I think it's lindsy C
Gibson is that the
author adult children of emotionally
immature parents yes it is a small book
David and it is a
masterpiece I ended up um I should have
highlighted my book with a sharpie and
just highlighted the I mean just crossed
out the parts that I didn't highlight
cuz I basically highlighted the entire
book what you're describing
is you were have you've been a part of a
world where it's your
job to live out your parents'
fantasies and unfortunately that's not
your job
actually fortunately it's not your
job right yeah
and that doesn't give you Liberty to
cash in your um integrity and lie to
your parents so the easy answer is I
follow two principles number one I only
speak if people can hear
me if your mom is struggling with a with
a delusion
disorder
um then she can't hear
you your dad probably can and so I would
tell my dad dad I need to talk to you in
person do you live in the same town as
him yeah okay Dad I need to take you to
a meal it needs to be just us too and I
have a heavy conversation I need
conversation I need to have with you I'm
safe and I'm okay but I need to have a
hard conversation with
you and the way I would approach this
conversation after you let him know that
way he at least comes ready he's not
just going to be eating a pancake and
all of a sudden you're like hey for the
last 5 years I've been lying to you all
the
time um so you let him know and he'll
sit down and say what's going on and and
it's important to say I'm safe I'm
healthy I'm
okay and then you let them know Dad for
five years I haven't told you the
truth and I would actually seek to
soften the blow a little bit and say for
the last three and a half years I've
been working at such and such marketing
firm as an account manager making a good
living I never went to college I lied to
you for four years or five years and I'm
sorry and then you stop
talking I wish there was more complex
like more like there was a switch to
flip there was something to like and
then do the there's
not but what he's going to want to know
out of the gate is my boy okay is my boy
safe what happened and then he'll get to
the I can't believe you lied to me and
he may have been telling his friends for
five years my son's going to be a doctor
my son's going to be a doctor he may
have been making decisions financially
because my boy's going to be a doctor my
boy's going to be a
doctor and no matter how successful you
are financially he's going to have to
wrestle with the fact that his son has
lied to him for 5
years so you're going to need to be very
graceful with what he says next because
he has not shown that he's got good
emotional regulation up until this point
so I wouldn't expect it just suddenly to
appear out of
nowhere but he's going to get some need
some
time fair
enough yeah sounds good okay what I
don't want you to do is to turn around
and make his response his fault make him
the victim and what comes next
okay yeah this is about you doing what's
right and if he chooses to just go
bananas and yell and scream and or walk
out on you whatever then he's Cho
choosing um to revert back to some
childhood Behavior he gets to do that
and then you're going to have to make
some hard decisions about what comes
next but you're going to keep your
character and your dignity and respect
intact
Fair
yeah so what are you g to say to him
just going to tell him the truth I'm
going to tell him
that I haven't been going to school for
the last five years I'm sorry for lying
to
you but uh I've been working nope no no
no no butts after that tell them you've
been working first and then say I've
been lying to you I have not gone to
school got it and then there's a period
at the end cuz there's not a butt after
that okay like cuzz butt suggests
like I haven't been doing this but it's
okay because it's not I've been lying to
you man I'm just going to sit here in
this awkwardness in intention I'm going
to own it and then I think it's
important for you to also tell them I'm
choosing to tell you because I know
mom's not
okay
yeah and normally I would tell you both
but I have more trust in you right
now and he might start weeping he might
get up and walk away what do you when
you imagine this knowing your dad CU I
obviously don't know him what do you
think he's going to
do since uh no I'm not the best right
now I think he might uh might try or
just not talk to me for a while okay I
hate that for
you I hate that for
you yeah but also I don't want the EP
potential adverse outcome for you to um
be the reason you don't be a person of
integrity and can we can we put a stick
in the ground a stake in the ground and
say I'm never going to lie again I'm G
always tell the
truth yeah does that sound
fair yeah I won't
okay even though this is going to be
hard are you at
peace yeah I'm pretty
I'm happy with myself just not this lie
I have okay let's let it let's let it
rip in and
um uh let me know how it goes right back
into the show and let me know how the
conversation goes and um this probably
won't come up but if your dad wants to
talk to me be happy to talk to him as
well sounds like he's had a really tough
go of it as of late but I want you to
pick up that book um we'll link to it in
the show notes it's just such a good
book I've got no Financial incentive
it's just one of those uh few books that
is so so so good and for everybody out
there secrets will kill
you Secrets will kill you tell the truth
we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone last year I came to
an inflection point I was exercising
regularly I was disciplined in my diet I
was getting regular blood work done and
I was working hard on my marriage I was
doing all the right things but I had not
dealt with old traumas and old stories
that were negatively impacting my
marriage my relationship with my kids my
work and me I'm the expert I teach
others what to do but I was slowly piece
by piece falling apart so I swallowed my
pride and with the encouragement of my
family and friends I reached out to a
therapist and started seeking true deep
healing a year later I'm a radically
different man all for the better and I
know finding a therapist in your local
community can be almost impossible or if
you do find one it's so expensive you
can't afford to go even if you wanted to
and that's why I love the work
betterhelp is doing in the world
betterhelp is online therapy with real
licensed therapists who are available on
your schedule when you contact better
help you will fill out a short
questionnaire and they will match you
with the licensed therapist plus you can
switch therapist at any time for no
extra charge you've been working so so
hard and now it's time to get to the
roote of your pain for permanent
extraordinary life change visit
betterhelp.com dealone today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com all right let's go back to man
the city with the best food in America
San Antonio Texas and talk to Stacy
what's up
Stacy hey Dr John how are you what up
I'm doing good how about you oh I've
been better it's been a pretty rough
year if I was doing great I wouldn't be
talking to you that's well played well
played I'm I'm laughing with you not at
you so what's up what's up if I wasn't
laughing I'd be crying right right I
totally get it what's up okay so I'm I'm
newly divorced and I'm trying to
navigate this and I'm having I'm having
some issues how long how long were you
married 21 years I'm
45 a long time you're 45 yeah uhhuh yeah
yeah we have two kids 19 and 21 oh gez
okay what happened
um long and short of things uh he
admitted to me he was cheating with a 20
something year
old oh
um
and
um just say it we're here just say
it uh throughout the divorce I I did
some
digging and I with the help of a
friend found him on
some vicarious
website and he's been going to intimacy
parties sex parties yeah yeah intimacy
parties sounds like people are telling
like secrets and passing
notes uh it's the best way I could
describe it I found out uh he had on
this web site that I found pictures and
videos of him doing things in my
home I found out he has been
crossdressing yeah that he has engaged
in the opposite sex and this was
unbeknownst to
me and um during the
divorce I was advised by my lawyer not
to confront him about this why I didn't
why why why why why
why she it was pretty much well I ended
up with darn near everything in the
divorce okay so it was just you were
going to win anyway and she want to
Cloud it up yeah okay all right all
right yeah so um before the divorce was
Final um I did start having um little
hints here and there of I know what
you've been doing and and so he he did
eventually confess to me that and he
said he has a sex addiction okay um and
I'm
GNA um there's a lot to this of course
I'm just going to unpack a little bit um
just to give him the benefit of the
doubt um and I don't know why I have to
give that to him but here I am hey can
we can we do something can we do
something are we gonna breathe yeah
let's breathe
um okay um yeah let's take a breath I'm
gonna do something I don't normally
do yeah I don't want to give him the
benefit of the doubt
oh okay I don't want to you know why cuz
he's not on the phone I don't really
care about him right now okay I care
about you and you you've been giving
people the the damn benefit of the doubt
for your whole
life you've been letting people run all
over you for your whole life
Fair actually that's not true people
have been running all over you when
you're a kid you can't help that I
shouldn't have said it like that I'm
sorry I still let him well here we
are I don't want to I don't want to hear
his story right now his Sab
story well
um I had cuz you're hold on cuz you're
sitting in the ash of that mess oh it's
so messy I
know he
ruined um I told him he took away my
kids's innocence he took away my dreams
my
future a bomb was just dropped and we
had no choice in the matter and I don't
know how to parent right now um I'm an
anxious
myth which shouldn't cause stress or
anxiety causes me to just lash out and
I'm almost into just Frozen mode like
things I just can't make
decisions and
I this man needs help for my kids's sake
he needs therapy he needs to get into
help find help but I have begged him and
he hasn't and I don't know how to parent
my kids I don't know if I should say
keep keep talking to him keep the the
Line open or if I should just step back
and let them see him for his true colors
because I feel like I'm constantly
catching the bombs he's throwing because
he's still screwing up in their lives
have you sat down with your kids and
talk to them about what happened what
you
found uh one not the
other why would think why one not the
other I don't think my son could handle
it why do you think that both of your
kids are adults why do you think that
he's uh he's very very sensitive kid he
actually actually woke me up at 11
o'clock last night and said Mom I just
need a hug he was crying that's right
and I and I don't know why I asked him
you come on let's talk like no I don't
want to talk I just need a hug that's
right you're home base for him right now
but can I tell you to a sensitive
kid as Dr Becky calls him deeply feeling
children yeah a parent who's not being
fully open especially to an adult child
the kid
knows and what that kid feels is your
rage and your anger and your complete
bewilderment walking around in the woods
like your house is like like like
walking around after a tornado has
knocked over everything just that days
you know yeah yeah and that poor kid
thinks it's his
fault because he doesn't know what's
going
on and so he feels crazy and you're
going to watch him revert back to very
childlike behaviors like Mom can I just
cuddle with you because that's his
nervous system trying to be regulated
because he doesn't know what is going on
and I'm not saying badmouth dad
I'm saying look your 19-year-old and
your 21y old in the eye and say I'm not
okay yeah I found out that your
father has violated the terms of our
marriage over and over and over
again for our entire
marriage yeah and that's not talk you're
not being egregious you're not like I
got videos none of that stuff right you
can say I've seen evidence of it it's
part of the reason we got
divorced but every and it caught me
completely off
guard yeah your Dad's sick he's not well
he's not
okay I know we love him I still love him
you love
him but he's not
okay very very far distance yeah that is
very different than that man's a piece
of crap and he that's different we're
not going to engage in that right I I
get to do that
right I get to say that but I will I
don't have the energy for that that's
right that's right you
don't um but hold on hold on before we
go to the next thing okay you can't you
you acknowledged all the hurting people
on this
thing yeah except for
Stacy
yeah and you've probably heard me if you
listen to the show ever I say this all
the time in these kind of situations but
this one's extra scary
the person who's most just has
evaporated in front of themselves is
you can you tell me like with all
honesty just like hand on your heart you
had no idea something was going on like
this I had no idea okay that's okay but
here's the deal you have to understand
the trauma that that is because now the
person you don't trust most in the world
is
you and it makes you feel crazy doesn't
it
yeah like how could you not know this
was going on in your house and here's
what I want to tell
you you were married to
somebody who violated you at every step
of the way this is not your fault
okay said what's wrong with me what
babe what is wrong with me your whole
world just blew
up your sense of self is gone your
marriage is gone the picture you had of
your kids moving off to college and you
and your husband creating this new world
when they were gone is gone it's all
gone of course you're lashing out of
people of course your body's anxious is
all bloody hell of course it
is and you've heard of fight or flight
we don't talk talk about it but there's
fight flight or freeze there comes a
moment when it's so the trauma is so
overwhelming your body just shuts the
system off because it can't it can't
compute at all I can't
respond what do I
do first thing is I want you to take as
deep breath as possible right now and
hold it
okay hold it for a count of four one 2 3
till almost Burns four
exhale did you let it out
yeah okay now I want you to take your
shoulders and I want you to burrow them
up under your ears as tight as you
possibly can for a count of three squish
them up there one two three and then
drop them all the way down
okay
yeah what room are you in right
now my car in your car all right I want
my son to hear y
okay I want you to count the
buttons on on your dashboard right now
on your uh radio your car radio does it
have buttons on it or was it one of
those new fangled computery buttony
things it's got buttons all right count
them for me count them out loud one two
three four five six seven oh there's a
lot eight okay that's good you get hey
you get the point here's what we're
doing often when people's entire world
had blown up their marriage was over
someone had their a loved one had walked
had passed
away I would hold their hand and we
would walk down the street and we' count
cracks in the sidewalk okay here's what
we're doing we're bringing our body to
right
now
okay we're still breathing right now the
sun is out right
now okay y I'm going to give you a
couple ideas on what to do next is your
divorce final final okay I I actually
just got my came back today okay and
that's both freeing and devastating
isn't
it it's scary
yeah and when you said you got almost
everything in the divorce do you are you
have economic stability or you got to go
to work on Monday oh no I'm fine
okay couple of things I want you to do
ASAP number one do you have a a
girlfriend or two or three that you can
call and tell everything
to
um I made a
deal with him that I would not yeah that
Deal's out the window Bye Felicia
gone okay that deal will kill you
Stacy yeah because what that deal is is
him destroying your life and you laying
on top of the burning shrapnel of the
bomb he
threw I'm not saying go run him in the
dirt publicly or make Facebook forums
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about you need some people in
your life that you can say everything's
over and I got to build from
scratch
uhhuh okay do you have two or three
women you trust you can sit down with
yeah is this quote unquote deal you made
is it legally binding is that a part of
your decree no
good it's not your job to carry him any
anymore
okay that's what I feel like I'm
carrying his burden that's not your
job the second thing I want you to do
after you get a group of women here's
the deal I want you to text them and I
want you to meet them for coffee I when
you say I want to meet y'all for coffee
and I want you to tell them out loud
I've selected you two or three women to
walk with me through hell are y'all
in okay I'm coming out a divorce nobody
knows the truth of what I just found
what I went through what my kids are
going through and I need a group of
women that I can text at 2: a.m. I need
a group of women I can text at noon and
you'll text me back when you can and
just say I love you or just say I'll be
up I'll be over with burritos
later yeah okay when you do that your
body will exhale a little bit because it
knows it's not carrying this whole thing
by
itself okay I love you enough to tell
you you cannot carry all this by
yourself it's too big yeah okay it's
yeah second thing I want you to do is I
want you to get a journal of some
sort okay you can go to Walmart for nine
bucks if you've got the money get a nice
one for 50 bucks with a leather bounding
on it and I want you to ride in it
because your kids are going to read this
after you pass away I want you to ride
in
it when you feel like I quote unquote
should do
something I shouldn't say this I should
go do this I need to do this I have to
do this I want you to write those things
down and I want you to draw an arrow
across that page and say his burden or
my
burden okay yeah I need to make sure
that they nope that's his
job his job is to explain to your kids
why he chose to cheat on his mom on
their mom not his mom on their mom for
years why he chose to have sex parties
in y'all's family home while they were
gone while y'all were gone that's his
his job that is not your
job
okay when he says I don't have any money
your mom took everything it is his job
to tell your kids the
truth it's his job to go get a job to
rebuild a career at 45 years old or
whatever he's got to do that's his job
not yours it's his job to go get
psychological care or medical care or
whatever he
needs your job is to make sure you're
financially and fiscally safe and sound
and to make sure your kids know they are
loved and they can always come home it
might mean you sell the house cuz I
don't want to be in that house anymore I
sold it good for you but I I moved to
our vacation home so yeah that's
probably dumb how far away is that it's
16 hours south of where I live I've got
friends here too okay all right all
right as long as you got a community um
I was going to tell you don't make any
decisions for the next six months or a
year but that's cool um I had to get out
of that house no that's I know that I
know that I know that but I'm glad you
sold it I'm glad it's gone
um here's a thing you probably don't
want to hear but hopefully you've
already done it but maybe you haven't
you need to go get a full battery of
blood test including all the STI tests
don't avoid that any longer okay have
you already done that I've done that I'm
clear you're clear you're good yeah ah
fantastic that was that was scary yeah
yeah I know I know waiting for that test
to be
okay and sometime soon you're going to
need somebody to talk to to process this
and what you're going to be processing
is yes the trauma and yes the questions
about how to answer your kids all the
mechanical stuff is fine but the big
thing you're going to be processing is
how do I trust me again because I've
missed something that big for 21 years
what you feel like you actually had the
wool pulled over your eyes for 21 years
you were married to somebody with a deep
profound pathology that hid from you and
hid from you and destroyed your life yes
it's not yours to carry but you do have
to pick up the ashes now because he's
gone
yeah when you ask me where do I start
I'm going to tell you the starting line
is
reality that's the next chapter of my
[Laughter]
book are you reading my book yeah I just
hit the
uh the bridge I just finished the bridge
about to get reality well you're in it
now here we go and what what I'm going
to tell you in that chapter is this take
out a piece of paper and say what is the
actual state of my
life what's my financial State who are
three or four people write their names
down and their phone numbers down in a
piece of paper that I can call if I need
to what is my you can't just not have a
job you have to have a purpose you got
to get up and go do do something on a
regular basis what is that thing going
to
be and uh I'm
disabled of course right and I don't say
of course I'm just saying why not add
another complex variable to the
situation right right so um but maybe
your purpose maybe your purpose
is moderating an online forum for women
who find out that their whole world has
been a sham yeah maybe it is working in
a disability rights office maybe it's
working at a Lo local un univers to help
students navigate the 5048 process right
it can be any number of things right it
may be working for an online University
from home on how to help students who
need some accommodations and and
navigating their their professors all
that kind of there's work to do there's
purpose in where you find yourself
okay and what I want to encourage you is
Do not sit at home with the shades
drawn that pours gasoline on the on the
the freeze part of your life
okay that pours gas on
it when somebody takes off to run a
marathon nobody says all right see you
in a few minutes they say I'll see you
in a few
hours it's easy when you're in this
process that you're in now of no fault
of your
own to get frustrated by how slow the
progress is you are running three
back-to-back marathons it's going to be
a while before you
have
peace that's why doing the next right
thing is so
important the next right thing is
calling a friend the next right thing is
seeing a counselor the next right thing
is making sure you have a journal where
you're getting all these thoughts and
these spinning things out of your body
and onto the
paper it's any kind of movement you can
do in line in alignment with your
disability what whatever you got to do
to do the next right thing and the next
right thing and I don't care if you feel
like it I don't care if you feel like it
just keep doing the next right thing
because you're going to open your eyes
in 18 months you're going to open your
eyes in two years you're going to open
your eyes in a
year and you're going to realize you're
breathing again and the sun came
out it's called
hope it's called hope Stacy you call me
anytime and I'll walk with you in any
situation you find yourself in never
think you don't have somebody in your
corner cuz I'm here call those friends
in your local community call them
today thank you so much for your bravery
we'll be right
back hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices overtime they become
Healthy Habits Like choosing to slow
down and make time for a daily practice
of Prayer and meditation one thing that
helps me every single day is hallow
hallow is the number one Prayer app in
the world on planet Earth and they're
giving you three free months to get
started and people always say you got to
meditate you got to pray you got to have
a spiritual life and for many of us we
don't even know what that means we don't
even know where to start that's where
hallow steps in three free months to
prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the LOI station that I love guided
prayers meditations and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life to figure out
what you even believe in the first place
and choose peace and remember Hall is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone toay and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90day trial that's hall.com
dealone all right let's go back out to
Richmond Virginia and talk to Sarah with
an H what's up
Sarah hey how's it going partan what are
you up
to just sitting at home with the
cold um that sounds awful what's up yeah
yeah I just reached out because um my
husband and I have been married for
about seven years and he just really
struggles with a lot of anger and a lot
of um anxiety and it just manifests
itself
into a lot of yelling and screaming and
um we have two young kids I'm pregnant
with our
third um and you know know then on top
of that if he gets mad enough at me
he'll break things like he'll Break um
you know gifts that I've given him or
he'll break uh he'll like smash food or
you know things that I've bought for
myself excuse me or that type of thing
and it's just really hard for me to know
how to handle it and I guess that's my
question is how do
I how do I navigate this in a way that's
healthy because you know my first
instinct when he smashes something that
I took a lot of time to pick out for him
or that he even asked for himself that I
bought for a birthday present or
something like that my first reaction is
be like well I'm never gonna buy you
anything ever again you know but I don't
I don't want to be vindictive I don't
want to
be um bitter so I'm just trying to
figure out how I am supposed to to
respond in a way that's protecting
myself and protecting my
kids um
yeah oh man Sarah can I just can I just
cut to the Chase and be super honest on
some things is that okay
yeah um I I think it's honest I want to
be as honest as I can um this is one of
those rare calls that
uh it it tightens my upper chest
T my wife would say she could see across
the room I see your jaw starting to
clinch and we need to
go yeah cuz she knows I'm about to get
myself into trouble okay this is one of
those moments and so I want you to know
that any in a world that you live in the
world you live in right now you will be
especially attuned to the sharpness in
my voice and I want you to know this is
not directed at you okay yeah yeah okay
and I am also talking in circles a
little bit to give my chance myself a
chance to breathe
okay okay the anger your H your
husband's anger is not the problem here
yeah your husband is a freaking
toddler
yeah and he acts like a
child and a child in a man's body can
hurt somebody
irreparably
okay and you're focused on well that I'm
just not going to make you gifts anymore
I'm focused on the women I've visited in
hospitals before who have their faces
knocked
in yeah
okay anxiety and anger don't manifest
into smashing things toddlers
do immature grown men do it's not a
result of what your husband's struggling
with it's a choice he is making in a
moment yeah or it's a choice he is
making to not deal with in the moments
that he's not anxious and
enraged okay I do know of some there is
some psychological issues where people
go quote unquote blind with rage fine
but then it's their job to deal with it
Upstream before they're blinded right
yeah and I'm speaking boldly about this
because I was a guy that was so buried
with anxiety I couldn't breathe and my
impulse was to smash things
and I didn't because I'm an adult not
cuz I'm better than anybody but because
I'm a grownup and I went and sought
professional help yeah
right so you're not going to like what
I'm telling you to do next okay I just
need you to know that that I'm on your
team okay
um and I I know there's a financial
reality to this I know there's a just a
reality reality to this
but if it's safe he gets a final
powerful written in stone with fire
boundary if you yell in this house again
if you smash something again if you
scream in this house again I'm leaving
with our kids or you're leaving
period if most of the time people call
the show and they and they water down
what's actually going on they sanitize
it a bit it's hard to say it out loud
yeah and what I just have a gut feeling
that's what you're having to do right
now and I honor that so I'm not going to
push you on it but if that conversation
can't be had for safety
reasons then you go find a safe place to
go for you and your two kids and your
third one on the way yeah and then you
communicate that in writing or through
an
attorney but when my toddler when my
daughter or my son was a toddler
I can't you can't explain things to
someone who is acting like a
six-year-old cuz they're six yeah and
someone who's in an adult body and goes
and grabs gift and smashes them just to
go
hahaa that's somebody who is being led
by their inner
child
yeah all right so I just said a lot of
heavy
stuff what do you feel do you think I'm
right am I crazy you push back on me no
I I think you're right I've you know
thankfully you know I we're already
seeing a marriage counselor I'm I have
seen counselors myself I've got you know
mentors and things like that that I've
kind of talked through this situation
with and everybody you know pretty much
agrees with that especially so some
think that I should just go ahead and
leave others think that like what you
said um if it's a conversation that I
can have in a safe way and I've pretty
much already told him that you know I've
I've
said if this happens again you know I'm
leaving and I'm taking the kids with me
until you can prove that you are working
on yourself and um and seeking the help
that you need because I I've tried
really long and and I think that's
what's hard is like we'll have you know
a good month or a good couple months or
a good couple weeks or things like that
and and I then it just kind of like LOLs
you into like a false sense of security
almost of like and then just being so
busy like I've got two small kids I work
full-time being pregnant like it's just
um it's a lot to like to deal with you
know 100% a third child that you're
having to like parent almost you know
listen that's exactly what you're doing
you're parenting a third child except
this third child has humongous
muscles yeah and if a toddler hits you
crazy is he's like he was a police
officer for many years like he's seen
women who have gone through this you
know he's
seen but he just like I don't think that
he believes like he fully understands
that like hitting me is wrong or hitting
our kids is wrong but I don't think he
because like this is the way that his
family has dealt with conflict he comes
from a very toxic family and not that
that excuses his behavior because he
could be different but it's like he just
does not see why that's why it's a
problem to yell and scream why it's a
problem to like as long as he's not
hitting me to like take his aggression
out on like an inanimate object you know
and so sometimes he'll be sorry and then
other times he'll be like oh well if you
had made me so upset yeah I
would piss me off that's a freaking
coward yeah blaming you for his childish
behavior because he always always has a
choice always and you do too yeah you do
too I think the challenge here is you
are telling him you have to stop doing
your thing because what you're doing is
wrong and what telling you is I don't
think it is and I think that's the wrong
way to go about
it the more effective way to go about go
about it is this you being Sarah say I
will not live in a
house where the man in the home smashes
things when he gets in a temper tantrum
period if you want to be married to
me you will not smash things in this
home I I won't be in a home where
somebody yells at me or my children
period yeah and if you want to disagree
with me your lawyer can talk to mine so
what you're doing is you're not saying
you need to do these things because
these things are wrong because he's
telling you I don't think they are what
you're saying is I won't be a part of
that
life yeah most people when they get to
where you are and they get right up to
this boundary line that they're about to
draw really firmly in the ground have a
couple of es one is economic it doesn't
sound like that's where you are you
could get an apartment and y'all could
be okay is that fair yeah I have family
family in the area could live with by
the way are your family telling you to
get the hell out for a long
time there yeah I mean I haven't told
them that he smashes stuff you know they
know that I'm kind of his verbal
punching bag because they've seen it in
some cases you know they've told
me you know if you ever need a break
like you don't have to call just come
like will be here you know so they're
very supportive that's them doing
whatever a pretty lukewarm job of trying
to tell you um yeah if you're ready to
run we got you yeah um without wanting
to trying to overstep their bounds if
you were my if you related to me I would
I would way overstep my bounds but I
tend to do that all the time um yeah
here's the other
thing often if economics are okay
there's a really powerful identity
problem
yeah those women can't make it work yeah
those women quote unquote break up their
family single moms are fill in- the
blank fill in- the blank fill in- the
blank
yeah yeah and I you know I have a very
string relationship with his family his
mom for many years has tried to break
our marriage up and
um she's just a very
manipulative person and so I've been
told by her you know that we're never
going to last you're never going to like
you're never going to make it you're G
to you know she's told my husband like
you better watch what you say around her
because she's going to take everything
from you and like take your kids from
you because that's what her husband
tried to do to her you know so I know
that there is an element of Pride there
of like you know I don't want to prove
this horrible person right you know that
I essentially and I know this isn't in
my mind it's like she doesn't get a vote
she doesn't get a vote I wouldn't let
that woman speak one whisper into my
mind or my heart
yeah not as far I mean I I mean
she what that what that becomes is this
a fear that others are going to judge
you as harshly as you're judging
yourself right now yeah and I'm going to
ask you to
stop you deserve to be safe you deserve
to walk into your own home pregnant with
child number three from a day of of of
full-time
work going home to a place where you can
drop everything and
laugh and be greeted by a former police
officer who gets the hell that is
women's lives these days and greet you
with a hug and a cup of tea and some
laughter yeah right or a funny dance or
a joke or at least picked up your
underwear not you walk into your home
and your body's preparing for war yeah
right yeah you deserve that that baby
that is just bathing in cortisol and
adrenaline right now deserves that yeah
everybody in that house your two babies
deserve that yeah and I want you just to
back just just be honest with yourself
and look back and say has anything I've
done or said or threatened has any of
that worked
no yeah so at some point you got to try
something new and if you listen to the
show for any length of time I almost
never tell somebody they gotta they got
to get
out but if your friends are telling you
and your family's
offering and I can tell in your voice
you're not telling me
everything it's a lot to tell you it's a
lot to I know I'm not blaming you I
wouldn't tell some weirdo on a podcast
either but I think you got to get with a
friend or two because also it's gonna be
very emotional it's gonna be heavy and
am I just saying emotional because
you're a pregnant woman I'm saying if I
was doing this I'd get emotional about
it okay I would have to have a couple of
people in my corner to say am I making a
right move what's the um what's a safe
apartment close to schools or what's
Child Care going to look like I want
have all those things lined up do I have
a bank account with my own money in it
yeah I get some people that will think
it through with you and if you think you
can have one less conversation that's
safe I'm all about it I'm all about it
yeah but if you don't I don't don't feel
compelled
to or it might be we can have a
conversation after I have locked the
gates because you're you're not
listening to my
boundaries
yeah and I I think it just feels like
he's almost like a different person like
when this stuff happens you know it's
not he's generally like a pretty
pleasant person when he's in a good mood
and things are going well but it's just
like he does not know how to handle life
just in general like stress and that's
his job that's his job you cannot solve
that for him yeah that's his Adventure
well and it's like just what you said
about you know a toddler he wouldn't let
our toddler behave that way no no no no
and by the way anger is good anger
points us to something that we care
about anger is not a bad
thing it's what we do with
it then he chooses to abuse his wife
with it he chooses to create like in
little kids a nervous system that will
never regulate until they get
professional help that's what he's
choosing to do that's on
him those are choices he's making so
what you have to do is to stop waiting
into his choices you've done that you've
done that for a long time and you've
probably put yourself in some pretty
risky dicey
situations
cool what you have to do is to begin to
solve for safety immediately I'm going
to solve for
safety solve for safety solved for
safety and tell them you call me I'm
happy to talk to
him give him some some uh a path out of
the madness that he's
in but I don't think this happens
through more talking and more talking
and more talking and more talking and
more
talking I think safety has you have to
solve for safety now and I want you to
ask yourself this has this been slowly
and quietly
escalating cuz I always look for trend
lines in these situations does someone
just have a bad day and smash something
and they felt like a about it and
they're so sorry and they go make it
right or did it start with slaming hands
on a table and then break a glass and
then smash a thing and then purposely
find something you made and break it to
and then start screaming and cursing if
you see this thing
escalating the data would tell me you're
next and I don't want you to be
next reach out to some friends tonight
and let start making a
plan you're worth being safe and you're
worth being
well we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
delone.org can't help I can't help you
we have had an very exceptionally heavy
last few weeks on this show there's been
really really massive serious problem
you know issues that haven't had clear
like hey do step a step B and step C and
you'll be great haven't had a whole lot
of that hence the reason I said earlier
I really need our time together for this
year to be done because we all need a
bit of a pallet cleanser we all need a
little time
apart so if you're listening to this
show and still with us you're not
sobbing somewhere in a park bench
um if you have something good happen to
you over the holidays will we just write
in and let us know we'll do a whole
segment on cool crap that
happened
CCT it's the new CCT segment called cool
crap that happened and uh we'll read it
we'll read it out loud and we'll
celebrate with you not to undermine and
minimize the negative stuff going on um
because it's a it's a wild world out
there man it's it's dark scary it's
hard but also there is joy and light out
there there is good things happening to
everybody and it's important that we
look for beauty even in the midst of
dealing with just chaos so if you have
some stuff that happens to you over the
holidays and you want to write in I'd
love love to love to love to hear about
it or if you're a couple weeks into New
Year's and you're keeping your
resolutions changing your tiny habits I
would love to hear about that too all
right as we wrap up the show it's from
the Great and Powerful ah Kelly Clarkson
song is since you've been
gone goes like this here's the thing we
started out friends it was cool but it
was all pretend yeah since you've been
gone you dedicated you took the time
wasn't long till I called you mine yeah
since you've been gone and all you'd
ever hear me say is how I pictured me
with you then all you that's all you'd
ever hear me
say but since you've been gone I can
breathe for the first time I'm so moving
on and now I get what I want Since
You've Been Gone Kelly
Clarkson the goat the Texas goat she's
so amazing love you guys take
[Music]
care